you
you can be pursuing a profession because
your parents aids the best thing you can
be pursuing a profession because you
think you will make a lot of money you
can be pursuing a profession because you
think you're going to get a lot of
attention none of that will do you any
good if you are not being honest with
yourself Oprah Winfrey
most people waste their lives living
someone else's dream they imprison
themselves they accepting the results of
other people's thinking they allow the
opinions of others to crush their own
inner voice you might have been beaten
down so often that now you stomp out
your own dreams before they even have a
chance to blossom you have become your
own little man it's time to rediscover
yourself the ancient Greeks had a
proverb knocking southpaw know thyself
it was used as a warning to pay no
attention to the opinion of the mattress
it's a valuable reminder that this is
your life you need to take charge if you
want success if you want to accomplish
your goals if you want your life to mean
something and has a significant impact
you start by drinking you to know
yourself to find your one board if you
set your course in a powerful new
direction for some people is really easy
and they get it right away for others
like myself it takes time analysis and
exercising from narrow down if you don't
do a lot of regular self reflection this
will be a challenging activity but
totally worth it when I found my one
word it changed my business and my life
you